salut on est en plein déconfinement et
j'espère que tout va bien de votre côté
que vous continuez à être prudent on ne
peut certes pas encore quitté la
martinique mais ce n'est pas bien grave
puisque chaque gens sur la première on
vous emmène en voyage
nous partons à la rencontre des
martiniquais qui vivent à l'étranger et
aujourd'hui je vous emmène à boston on
parie retrouver son bras testing y une
martine cazes qui s'y installer depuis
quelques années et ça a l'air de lui
plaire
[Musique]
salut son bras salehi me once a l'air
d'être super un botté sur quoi
exactement alors ce qui pose que ces
lots mais c'est un fleuve c'est c'est un
fleuve en fait donc ici on est jeune
donc la grand ville de boston d'ailleurs
en fait personne c'est pas là d'accord
et de l'autre côté du fleuve
il ya donc la ville de cambridge et
c'est là pour votre honte ces grandes
universités comme harvard elena qui tue
et martiniquaise et tu viens boston
depuis combien de temps alors je suis
ici depuis six ans on m'a sixième année
au départ ça devait être une expérience
d'un an
et puis j'en ai pas eu accès alors j'ai
rempilé pour une deuxième année une
troisième duel en fait non pas par
l'arrivée et tu fais quoi à boston je
suis enseignante en mathématiques
donc j'étais enseignante au collège et
personnes en martinique
et si j'ai eu un poste au lycée
international de boston qui enseigne les
mathématiques mais aux élèves y en a
beaucoup des élèves francophones
justement du côté de boston
alors en fait ouais on est une ville en
fête qui accueille pas mal de personnes
avaient relâché et on a pas mal d'élèves
en fait notre lycée est un lycée
international donc on a deux cursus un
cursus qui ne prépare au diplôme du
baccalauréat international en anglais et
un cursus qui prépare au diplôme du
baccalauréat français est en fait dans
notre établissement n'a vraiment
moitié-moitié où les élèves auront
beaucoup de cette ville boston on
connaît le nom on n'a peut-être jamais
visité c'est le cas de la plupart
d'entre nous moi je connais pas du tout
je connais un petit peu l'histoire
qu'est ce qu'il ya de beau à faire un
boston alors les abonnés sur la côte est
des états unis donc on est vraiment
entouré tôt donc pour ruiner jeune
antillaise comme moi c'était nécessaire
ça fait du bien il ya vraiment vraiment
le foyer culturel et intellectuel
quand même la première ville qui a été
fondée aux états unis c'est dans cette
ville tel le premier jardin public la
première école la première université
donc ils vont mettre en parle
donc en fait c'est une riche c'est une
ville très très riche culturellement
parlant et il voit là il ya tout plein
de choses intervalle d'environ on est
entouré de la mer et montagne de la
campagne au collet ce qui est fatiguant
on peut faire du bateau si vous mangez
locative on en oublie pas qu on a new
york et a3 avait mis en voiture à côté
donc quand tu vois ça demande un petit
peu de peps je sais pas comment ça se
passe à boston précisément mais de ce
qu'on voit aux informations la situation
des états unis particulièrement
compliqué en ce moment avec locaux vides
19 beaucoup de cas beaucoup trop de
morts malheureusement du côté de boston
quelle est l'ambiance comment ça se
passe et ce que vous êtes confiné
visiblement non puisque tu t'es dehors
quelle est la situation exacte par
rapport au courant navire lui en fait
une politique notamment confinement
selon les états c'est à dire que ici on
est autorisée toujours à sortir bien
évidemment comme un comportement de nos
analyses et de ne sortir que pour le
strict nécessaire
mais ce n'est pas un verre vous sortiez
à l'aller seules recommandations sont
nous reste compliqué quand on rencontre
beaucoup 3 nuls
voilà quoi noah à moi je viens on est un
peu épargné on a accueilli 800 cas dans
d'autres styles depuis début mai on
entend beaucoup de chômage aux etats
unis
beaucoup de personnes qui se retrouvent
sans emploi du jour au lendemain alors
c'est assez particulier quand on voit ça
de la france on ne s'imagine pas mais
des millions de personnes se retrouvent
du jour au lendemain sans travail sans
protection juridique ni même sanitaire
en social ça va être compliqué alors pas
pour vous à boston puisque par rapport à
la superficie de la ville où nous semble
être assez épargné mais sur l'ensemble
des états unis on a vraiment
l'impression quand on voit que c'est une
catastrophe en fait la situation et
comme le club du pays et à ses
capitalistes
en fait on a pas on n'a pas la vie si la
protection pas mon enfance ne serait ce
que la profession de santé serait
difficile et cher tout le monde là-bas
mais moi j'ai couverture sociale je
crois le cas nous facture santé des
meilleurs
je ne sais absolument pas ce qui
m'arrive grèce si jamais japon maladie
et je sais que sa part de bing et deux
de douleur alors écoute prend soin de
toi fais attention bien évidemment
[Musique]
arm est vraiment de faire ta
connaissance et nous faire visiter un
petit peu nous faire voir la ville c'est
vraiment génial
waouh ça a l'air d'être vraiment
vraiment très très beau défi de se
retrouver sur l'eau comme ça ça va être
particulier en ce moment et on espère te
revoir très bientôt aussi en martinique
c'est prévu avec grand plaisir dès que
possible même si je suis ici et que bon
on est rassuré alors merci beaucoup son
bras dans cette petite visite de boston
et à très bientôt
merci à très bientôt j'espère que cette
visite de boston vous aura fait plaisir
à vous aussi on se retrouve très vite
sur martinique la première après pékin
[Musique]